Hogwarts Legacy just dropped the
official launch trailer for the game
presumably this is the final trailer
before release and there are quite a few
lore and story details contained within
seeing this is really our last chance to
speculate before launch I wanted to take
one final look at what we've learned or
at least what we think we know about the
story and its character so far first
we'll talk about the idea of ancient
magic which seems to be the core plot
point for the game then we'll highlight
some of the major characters that we're
going to meet on our journey and then
we'll take a look at the most recent
trailer to see where it can maybe fill
in some of the gaps and help tie
everything together so I believe the
central plot point for Hogwarts Legacy
is centered around the idea of ancient
magic you see Hogwarts itself is a
stronghold of ancient magic plus
Hogwarts legacy's main logo features a
symbol which the devs use throughout the
game to represent ancient magic now the
phrase itself ancient magic is not
entirely new to The Wizarding World and
its lore there are several references to
it within the Original Series in Harry
Potter and the Half Blood Prince we
learned that a graduating Tom Riddle was
still completely fascinated by Hogwarts
he actually turned down numerous career
opportunities offered to him only to end
up working at Borgen and Berks but
Borgen and Burks was not his first
choice no Tom had originally hoped to
stay on at Hogwarts as a teacher
Dumbledore believed his primary reason
for wanting to stay was due to his
strong attachment to the school not
unlike Harry Tom had a tragic childhood
so his best and happiest memories were
all made at Hogwarts his second reason
for wanting to stay at Hogwarts though
is far more interesting for the story of
Hogwarts Legacy you see Dumbledore
believed that riddle wished to stay at
Hogwarts to further study the ancient
magic contained within the castle itself
secondly Dumbledore told Harry the
castle is a stronghold of ancient magic
undoubtedly Voldemort had penetrated
many more of its Secrets than most of
the students who passed through the
place but he may have felt that there
were still Mysteries to unravel stores
of magic to tap throughout the seven
book series we do see small glimpses of
this magic such as the moving staircases
the various trick steps false doors and
even the room of requirement of course
the school was built by four of the
greatest witches and wizards of their
age and godric Gryffindor Helga
Hufflepuff Rowena Ravenclaw and Salazar
Slytherin so it would seem they found a
way to tap into this ancient magic
themselves as they were actually
building the school it's also possible
the physical location of the castle
contained this ancient magic as if it
were part of the Earth where the
founders decided to build according to
one Legend of Wizarding World lore the
founders chose their specific location
for Hogwarts only after discovering a
half-buried pensive in the ground this
pensive became the very same one that
would be used by numerous Headmasters
and headmistresses during their time at
Hogwarts now even Dumbledore admitted
that he did not know all of the castle
secrets and at least one of the reasons
riddle wanted to remain at Hogwarts was
so he could further study the ancient
magic held within there were even
occasions during the seven book series
where the castle appeared to be almost
sentient take for example an order of
the Phoenix when the Headmasters Tower
sealed itself away from high Inquisitor
Dolores Umbridge we also know magical
creatures which are going to be featured
prominently in Hogwarts Legacy they also
can possess forms of the ancient magic
when researching for the first task in
Goblet of Fire Harry reads a line about
dragons which states dragons are
extremely difficult to slay owing to the
ancient magic that imbues their thick
hides which none but the most powerful
spells can penetrate and later we get a
line from Voldemort himself where he
says Dumbledore invoked an ancient magic
to ensure the boy's protection as long
as he is in his relations care then of
course we have what is likely the most
powerful form and most recognized form
of ancient magic throughout the entire
series and that came in the form of
Lily's sacrifice for her son Harry this
magic something that Voldemort would
later admit was something he should have
foreseen is what caused the Avada kedav
recurs to rebound off Harry's head and
then it would have likely killed
Voldemort had it not been for the
horcrux as he created that direct
sacrifice the act of Lily stepping in
front of her son taking the killing
curse for him placed a protection on
Harry that would be incredibly important
for the whole series in fact without it
the series piece wouldn't have even
happened and so what all these examples
of ancient magic have in common is that
it can be very unpredictable it's almost
this primordial Force that's part of the
very fabric of reality and just from a
pure gameplay perspective you can see
why it would make sense to choose
ancient magic as a core mechanic it's
something that's part of the original
lore but by its very nature is
unpredictable because of this it gives
the developers more freedom to explore
new ideas that may be unfamiliar with
fans of the original series but also
ideas that can work within the overall
framework of the lore it works just as
well from a story perspective because
they can pull from the lore we already
know by connecting to iconic locations
such as Hogwarts powerful creatures like
dragons and maybe even ancient witches
and wizards like the founders or
possibly even Merlin The Wizarding World
even has the perfect device for
exploring ancient history in the form of
appensive we know we're going to spend a
lot of time at Hogwarts but there's
always the possibility we could see even
more locations through the use of a
pensive even if we don't physically
travel there ourselves this whole
concept of ancient Magic provides the
necessary vehicle for the devs at
Avalanche to explore familiar touch
points from the series but to also give
us a fresh new experience we'll likely
learn more about ancient magic and our
connection to it by interacting and
getting to know the main characters for
the game while there have actually been
quite a few characters confirmed we'll
keep our discussion today focused on 12
specific characters Each of which have
been highlighted by the Hogwarts Legacy
social media team in recent months that
recognition came in the form of these
character cards which contained a
picture and also a brief bio of the
characters we'll start with leasar fig
as he would appear to be at the core of
the investigation around ancient magic
we know the player character starts as a
fifth year and that we have some sort of
special ability to perceive and master
ancient magic but more on that in a
second when we talk about that new
trailer fig serves as the professor of
magical Theory during our time at
Hogwarts his character card also
mentions his wife Miriam in her
worldwide research on The Disappearance
of ancient Magic from the world it's
also said he originally had aspirations
to work for the ministry of magic but
chose to go travel with his wife and
instead unfortunately for them both fig
grew weary of Miriam's search and
eventually chose to leave for Hogwarts
instead tragically Miriam was later
killed during her travels and now fig
carries this huge burden of guilt and
regret at not having been by her side
and so with her death he is now
dedicated his life to completing her
Mission and to also understand how and
why she died he's described as
knowledgeable and a character who will
be one of our greatest allies throughout
the game now whereas fig only had
aspirations to work for the ministry our
next character is actually employed by
them as a high-ranking official George
osrick is known as charming and a
decades-long friend to both eliezar and
Miriam he's skillful at solving riddles
which is one of the reasons Miriam
sought his help before she died it said
she had recently discovered an
indecipherable puzzle and then decided
to reach out to osrik he made his
initial appearance in the state of Play
trailer and from that trailer we know
he's seen at least once alongside fig
and our main character now the ministry
of magic as a whole even if our
character doesn't physically go there
themselves it seems like it is going to
play an absolutely vital role in our
adventure in fact numerous Hogwarts
professors are confirmed as having
worked for the ministry starting with
Matilda Weasley a former curse breaker
for the ministry of magic now at
Hogwarts she's our Transfiguration
Professor who also serves as Deputy
headmistress she introduces us to the
room of requirement and also presents us
with our Field Guide book which actually
comes to his courtesy of the ministry of
magic there's also Professor sharp our
keenly astute potions master who had a
lengthy career as an auror Professor
garlic are muggle-born herbology
Professor who appears to be the
antithesis of sharp with her Charming
personality there's Professor Ronan who
is our charms instructor and he seems to
Value friendship and teaches with an
unorthodox style focusing mainly on
learning through gameplay and lastly we
have Dinah heckett our Stern but likable
defense against the dark arts Professor
who once worked at the ministry in the
department of mysteries oh and we can't
forget our Headmaster Phineas nigellus
black who only took the position due to
the power and Prestige that came along
with it black of course goes on to be
widely ridiculed for being one of the
worst Headmasters in the the history of
the school it's also true that other
professors have since been mentioned and
even confirmed however we only have the
character card bios for the ones I
mentioned here and among the ones I've
mentioned four of them have direct
connections to the ministry then we have
ostric which would bring us to five
characters with that close of a
connection and of course that's only
dealing with confirmed characters we
know the ministry has their eye on our
player character as the wizard Field
Guide presented to us by Professor
Weasley was indeed provided to us by the
ministry of magic Sebastian sallow poppy
Sweeting natsai onai and Amit the car
are four students they've also
highlighted with these character cards
we learned a little bit about their
backstories through the cards and it
would appear each of them will weave in
and out of our story along the way
Sebastian actually had an entire trailer
dedicated to what they've described as
an optional quest line whereas poppy
played a key role in the story Mission
we recently had a chance to go Hands-On
with as for the antagonists first up we
have the goblin ranrock randrock appears
to be using some sort of corrupted
Magical Force that signified with the
red eyes and even some of the attacks
showing these dark red and black effects
which indicate this corrupted nature we
even see this in the dragon fighting
ring on our mission with Poppy before
even getting to the dragon ring we find
a piece of goblin metal that poachers
are using as Dragon collars once we
actually get into the fighting Ring We
again see this red effect on the collars
themselves possibly showing that
connection to the corruption now this
corruption is still a bit unknown as
well is it a dark form of the very
ancient magic we're attempting to learn
more about throughout the game certainly
possible and then there's also the dark
wizard Victor Rookwood who has formed an
uneasy alliance with ran Rock so all of
this brings us to the most recent
trailer which the Hogwarts Legacy
marketing team has described as a launch
trailer this one gives us a small
glimpse at the overall story and even
though it's a small glimpse I think it's
probably the most they've said in quite
some time about the story personally I
think it strikes the perfect balance of
showing us plenty of teases without
giving away too much now with this
trailer immediately from the jump we
hear who I believe is Professor Weasley
speaking and she's is describing our
unique start as a fifth year at Hogwarts
in light of your unique situation
joining us as a fifth year we get a
glimpse at some professors we've already
been introduced to and one we're seeing
for the first time Weasley talks about
how the professors have been asked to
give our character additional
instruction outside of the ordinary
curriculum which again makes sense
considering our late arrival one of my
favorite lines from the trailer has to
be this one here I am wary of how much
time the new fifth year seems to be
spending away from the castle now we
know a few locations that have been
confirmed such as hogsmead the Forbidden
Forest but that particular line right
there gives me hope we'll be visiting
even more iconic Wizarding World
locations throughout the game we
mentioned Rookwood a bit earlier we do
get a glimpse of him here he appears to
be searching for our character in
hogsmead and it perhaps our most clear
statement yet on the unusual ability
that our character possesses I have a
rare ability to see Whispers of ancient
magic and then we even get a shot of the
book that's included with the
collector's edition of the game which
fans have speculated for months has a
connection to Merlin and possibly even
Morgana and the ancient feud between the
two the rest of the trailer shows off
some apps absolutely epic action
sequences including what looks to be an
insane battle with this towering Knight
now quick interesting note about this
one here if you freeze it at just the
right frame you'll see the Goblins are
actually doing battle against this
Knight so maybe this is a force not
under their control possibly by fig
maybe something else entirely that's
just attacking everyone who knows but we
don't have long to wait now there are
quite a few scenes in this trailer
pulled directly from the story Quest
that I recently had a chance to play
myself and if you'd like to see how that
one plays out without any commentary
whatsoever check out the video on the
right side of your screen now as always
thank you all so much for watching I'll
talk to you again soon